[Music]
dear dr arn just like millions of other
students
i was not prepared for the grief i would
feel in missing many of my last moments
at college
in the grand scheme of life my grief
over graduation
in a missed month of school is seemingly
minuscule
but this grief bears witness to a deep
love for hillsdale college
not just as a degree granting
institution but as the facilitator of
human flourishing through real
human interaction the physical place of
hillsdale college matters for seniors
because this is where we have learned
how to actually love our neighbors
and to do the right thing at the right
time
in the pursuit of truth goodness and
beauty
we must not forget the gift of time we
do not know what tomorrow may bring
in the end i understand that this is an
unprecedented time in our nation's
history
but even and especially in times of
uncertainty and fear
our understanding of human bodies and
souls must
influence our actions i argue that we
cannot sacrifice what it means to be a
human being
right now for a future in which we are
not even guaranteed life and breath
hillsdale's commencement is a claim
about the nature of the human experience
i trust the college's wisdom and
discernment in making this experience as
safe as possible
but i ask most fervently that the class
of 2020
would be able to experience commencement
as the localized
personal and profound experience it is
meant to be
sincerely hadiya ritchie class of 2020.
this is the 168th commencement
ceremonies of hillsdale college
i can't tell you how grand it is to see
you here thank you
the subject matter of commencement is
not the events of the day
but the past and the future and eternity
it's a very beautiful thing to attend
hillsdale college right now
in these four years they have a chance
to lay the foundation for their
adulthood
and they've got the energy for it and
the curiosity for it
and the openness for it and they turn it
to the best account
and it's urgent and active and hard
all the time and they joy in it
this is called commencement that's what
it's about
because now they must live the right way
and that's how they can be a blessing to
the world they're going into
and they will you see
the united that these seniors are going
to be remembered
as one of our greatest classes in our
very long and distinguished history
they did something heroic they did
something great
because you're doing this important
thing and it's come into a culmination
and it's really the first important
thing in your life that you've done on
your own
and it gets crushed so i started telling
them right at the beginning
you've got to keep your chin up and work
your tail off what are we whiners around
here
they just love that see why this
is valuable and it requires intensity
and effort
and the overcoming of obstacles to
complete it
and obstacles are always in the way
every day
these seniors responded to that
beautifully
and they're here today as a symbol
of the strength of the association that
a good
college can achieve
you